Hmm.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 26,
2017 what's going on?
How,
how you doing?
How are you doing this fucking Monday morning?
God is global warming and making your raw fish hot.
Um,
climate change.
Let's give it a nicer name.
So
what are we going to use?
F was a euphemism.
Photosynthesis.
Jesus Christ,
the,
the photosynthesis fucking police.
There's nothing people enjoy more on the internet other than jerking off to
people sold into the sex industry.
Sex slow.
What do they call it?
A human trafficking is fucking,
um,
correcting somebody.
Jesus fucking Christ.
The amount of gold I give you half God for fucking bid.
Okay.
A pasty fucking dope.
Like me.
Make some mistake every once,
every fucking five minutes on a podcast.
All you fucking cunt cannot wait to go on the Internet and just read me the riot
act like,
like Europe or some sort of fucking award.
And in,
in the science industry,
you know,
whatever the fuck they call it,
the science circuit.
So they always call a radio guy.
Say that yacht day.
Yeah.
We are working the circuit.
You mean doing the road?
I didn't realize there was a circuit.
Um,
everybody fucking common at me.
Photosynthesis Yard.
I think you met Paula nation laughing my ass off.
You know Jesus fucking Christ.
Let me leave and let me look it up right now.
Paul [inaudible].
Dot,
dot dot.
Dot.
Paula nation.
Why is I've ever been a ball player named that pollination is the process by
which pollen is transferred to the female reproductive organs of a plant.
Thereby enabling fertilization to take place.
Like all living organisms,
seed plants,
ever singer may single major goal to pass their genetic information onto the,
all right,
well how the fuck does it get there?
Well,
it's pollination.
Oh,
I see.
I said photosynthesis.
All right,
so that's what I thought photosynthesis was.
Okay,
here we go.
Photo synthesis.
That doesn't have a good spring.
Paula nation
photo
whoa
synthesis.
That's how you have to bring them up.
Now.
Batting number 22 Oh
oh
this is,
that's more like the MMA
fighting out of the red corner.
You can see that.
Guess what?
We would just read definition
fighting out of the red corner,
the process by which green plants and some other organisms use sunlight.
It's a design,
um,
from carbon dioxide to water and water.
The process by which green plants in some other organisms,
you sunlight to synthesize foods from carbon dioxide,
carbon dioxide and water.
What does synthesize me?
See this is what happens.
Are they using auto tune synthesize,
s y s y s sort of synthesize.
You know what I meant?
All right.
Sin.
Sin,
the SIS synthesize.
All right.
The combination of ideas to form a theory or system.
Well,
that doesn't sound like the definition.
They were looking for synthesis.
Synthesis.
Okay.
Oh,
come on.
You fucking cunt.
Plural.
Synthesis to formation of a chemical compound through the combination of a
simple compound of elements.
See Multi you guys that knew that I used the wrong word.
You couldn't fucking tell me what all this shipment.
You don't unless you own a lab coat,
right?
Photosynthesis.
The process by which green plants and some of the organism uses.
Use Sunlight to synthesize foods from carbon dioxide and water,
like digest them and turn them into something edible.
So some con right now,
like you,
yeah,
shut up.
All right,
there you fucking beaker redone.
Can't fuck you when you're black framed glasses.
All right.
Least I own my work.
Unlike you and the science industry,
who owns your shit and what do they use it for?
You're out there trying to feed plants using sunlight,
right?
And all of a sudden they come up with a new way to send our magic.
Mike says what?
I'm starting to call our missiles,
Magic Mike's.
That's what we have in this country.
We,
we got the top of the line fucking missiles,
you know,
like the Mercedes and the Ferrari's in f one top of the line.
We got the magic Mike's.
We shoot them into city a only kill the bad people,
right?
Then all these terrorist groups,
they like the fucking,
uh,
the,
who's the guys in the orange cars this year,
that fucking cars blow up every God damn fucking race.
One of the Goddamn drivers,
cause you know what?
Fuck you guys,
I'm taking a race off.
I'm going to go drive the Indy 500 he left Formula One to drive a fucking Indy
five,
either an Indy car race in America,
the Mclaren Honda.
It's their like the terrorist group.
You know what I mean?
You don't know what the fuck's going to happen,
but we got the magic mix.
Magic bikes,
photosynthesis,
um,
Paula nation,
whatever you guys got me.
I'm the fucking,
what's that guy?
[inaudible] the Guy Yardi you said blow me like a cello or whatever.
I don't think I've ever related to a rapper more in that moment,
you know,
is as I am.
That's what it took.
You know,
not talking about this and talking about that.
It's the fact that dead poor bastard.
Dot.
A cello was a wind instrument.
I was like,
you know what?
This sounds like the kind of person that I went to summer school with and you
know what?
I bet he has other talents.
Okay.
Other than being able to memorize all you fucking cons out there where they were
able to memorize what photosynthesis was versus Paula nation.
Can I ask you a question?
Seriously.
In all seriousness,
this,
where did it get you?
Huh?
Other than getting to be some content,
a cocktail party,
you know,
what are you as social life,
you can talk photosynthesis and fashion.
Um,
you know,
by the way,
thank you for correcting me.
I don't know how it's going to affect my life,
but there was just something about the joy that people took him in and
correcting me that I,
I took umbrage with that.
I use that correctly.
Or is that the wrong you word?
You know what?
You know what I like about Twitter is I don't even have to read anymore.
I'll just say shit that I think is right and you guys can correct me.
All right?
I'll learn things.
You guys can feel better about yourselves.
You know,
at dad tickets say Yah,
it's a little fucking do they call a little surf and turf.
So to scratch my back,
I scratch your back.
I Dunno what you see book Beyonce says she's got a Gig at the fucking Hollywood
bowl.
That was probably what?
A fucking talented family,
you know what I mean?
That's how talented that family is.
Like she can't even get anybody to look at her at the Thanksgiving table because
they're fucking oldest sister sold out the rose bowl.
You know what I mean?
She's like the fuck up of the family cause she only sold out the Hollywood bowl.
Honey,
honey,
quiet down.
Quiet down.
Your sister is talking about what it was like to be singing bootylicious as the
stealth bomber flew over the stage.
Okay.
Um,
was that wrong to do that?
Speaking of pollination,
will this get the beehive after me?
Yeah.
It was funny about all of those fucking groups.
This so up the ass of the artist.
I swear to God she would fucking,
she wouldn't take her God damn shoes off to run across the street and make it
fucking emergency call on one of those old telephones back in the day.
Let's just say there wasn't cell phones.
If she saw one of you guys sit on the side of the road,
she would give a shit about you.
What's another one?
Who's another one's got a big following,
you know,
that was it.
It's the beehive
as it Mariah Carey have one.
You know what I mean?
I don't know what it is.
It's just,
I dunno what,
there's something about acting like a complete asshole and treating people like
shit that just women can't get it up a certain type of woman.
They can.
They can't get enough of it.
What is it?
Why?
You know,
something
I always wanted if,
if more women were like Rhonda Rousey of the current champion that I don't know
the name of,
my apologies.
Um,
if more of them took like MMA could actually beat the fuck outta you,
would they just not walk around being mean to each other as much,
you know,
guy,
I think that's the only reason why guys aren't as mean as women are because
personally speaking anyways,
because I know that 90% of guys can beat the shit out of me.
Right.
At the very least land,
a couple to my,
you know,
and I fucking bruise like the Irishman.
I am,
you know,
stop the fight,
two punches in.
I don't need that shit.
So I tried to basically,
you know,
mind my ps and qs.
What does that stand for?
High.
You're fucking brainiacs.
Um,
what does it stand for?
Let me find out.
Like you know,
and I have to fact check everything so I don't get fucking get people at my ass
again.
Mine.
Your p's and q's minding your ps and qs.
P n Q origin
or is it yeah,
it's PS and qs.
Not P and Q.
Mind your p's and q's.
You fucking cunt.
How do you not say that without you fucking cunt.
Okay.
What does mind your p's and q's come from?
This is going to be a very special educational podcast.
It's just going to be me.
All right.
Okay.
If you've ever been told him mind your p's and q's,
it might have struck you as a rather odd thing to do.
Well that's a nice way saying it was annoying.
I think anytime soon we say,
hey,
mind your p's and q's.
I,
my immediate thought was,
who the fuck is this guy?
Okay,
tell me to mind these things.
Uh,
I won't sit some eighties comedy telling me to mind these things.
the concept seems reasonable enough,
behaving,
behaving well,
not giving offense,
but quite,
but quite what the letters p and Q have to do with this is a little more
mysterious.
Why not B and d?
O Jesus.
Here's something.
Why not be a,
can you just fucking get a whole entry?
All right.
Okay.
Yeah,
there's a whole fucking,
this guy's just,
you know what some funny about these fucking assholes who write for a living.
They just can't get to it.
They feel if they don't take up a whole fucking page or bill,
maybe there's people out there that enjoy reading.
Maybe it's sad.
Okay,
I'll,
do you know what?
I'll take the ride.
Why not be in d or m and m m n n or any other combination.
Sadly,
as it often is the case with the more intriguing terms in the English language,
there is no definitive answer to the,
Oh,
well what the fuck?
Okay.
No one knows what it means.
This last meeting were like Trenton,
Dah,
Dah.
Okay,
mean queen and not queen.
Okay.
What the best possible manners.
Mind your dancing.
I Dunno.
The Oxford dictionary doesn't even know the answer.
You know what's funny?
They don't even have the fucking answer yet.
They still,
they still couldn't.
They couldn't keep their mouth shut.
Could they?
Yeah,
I bet somebody else has one.
Somebody at this point see Internet.
Somebody's going to take a guess.
Yeah.
All right.
What does it mean ever been told to mind your p's and q's every yes,
yes.
That's why I'm here.
What's your working in mechanical printing press at the time?
Chances are you are fairly subtly being told to mind your manners,
but what exactly are your p's and q's?
The short answer is no one really know
why is it that?
Why?
Why is it dead right there?
Mind your p's and q's.
What does it mean?
And then boom,
nobody knows.
Okay.
What,
what kind of a fucking ass you ever been told to mind?
Your p's and q's?
Well,
you work in a printing press.
Fucking two paragraphs.
You know what I did is because this is delving into the world of people that
like to know shit.
So even when they don't know shit,
they still have to fucking write three paragraphs on it.
All right?
Fuck all of this.
Fuck all it.
There's,
I was just frustrating.
Um,
anyways,
and I am actually,
no,
before I looked up those things before I remembered that you guys corrected me.
You know,
maybe you guys weren't being assholes.
Maybe just trying to help me out.
You don't snakes,
I'm hanging around a socialite,
you know,
social,
as far as I can tell,
it's just a way,
well,
red gold digging whores,
you know,
like how did you get there?
You got to be married to somebody rich.
If you just Wa,
if you just pleasant to be around,
you don't really have a fucking job.
I mean,
somebody is going to be bring,
bringing home the Bacon,
right?
Bringing home the Bacon.
Where did that come from?
You know,
I mean unless you're,
unless you're a farmer,
I don't know.
You let you your work in a,
unless you're a butcher,
I was 20 fucking paragraphs.
A later point is nobody really knows.
Um,
anyways,
I'm actually uh,
relieved believe it or not because I did the big Papi roast on a,
what was it,
Thursday night and thank Christ it went about as great as it could have gone.
I am not a big fan of doing rose.
You know what the last roast I did was I did the portray.
So Neil roast like 15 years ago or something.
Whenever the hell that was,
that was the last time,
cause I never understood doing one unless you were friends with the person.
Right.
But I always like is always see guys like Lenny class it dead.
And uh,
Dennis Leary,
uh,
you know,
they're always hanging out at red sox games,
getting up in the broadcast booth.
And I'm like,
I would love to fucking do some shit like that.
I need to do more Boston shit.
So this thing came up and I'm like,
ah,
why did it have to be a roast?
And Nia chimed in.
She's like,
so I said,
yes,
I'll do it.
Then I had no time to fucking right cause that was dealing with a bunch of other
shit.
And uh,
all of a sudden it was a few days away.
And um,
I dealt with that race,
that race,
that roast the way this country dealt with a y two k,
you know what?
We waited until the last second.
Then we were like,
oh my God,
what are we going to do?
Like we treated it like a fucking giant term paper.
That's what I did.
Um,
and it was a wraith to Thursday when I was trying to say a race to the finish
line,
a race against time.
Um,
and I actually figured out how my brain works when it comes to those fucking
things.
It's the same way it works for Standup,
but for some reason you think like a roast.
I have to sit down and write jokes.
That's not what I needed to do.
I needed to put my daughter,
I had to put my daughter in the stroller and walk around the block.
And then I had to,
uh,
I smoked a cigar by myself on the back porch and I just kept thinking of shit
and I would just videotape myself saying it.
And then I had all these videos and I forget if I told you this guys,
you guys this on a,
Oh,
sorry,
on Thursday,
but I just watched the videos and I just spliced together every good one,
just transcribed them.
And then I had the block of everybody,
right?
I had poppy Gronk,
Pedroia,
Josh Wolfe,
Lenny Clack,
Sarah Tiana,
Anthony Mackie,
and everybody that was on the fucking thing and I just would put them underneath
each name.
And then I just then made a new document and I just took the best of the best,
slid him over,
then I put them in the best possible order.
Then I went in order of person and then I smoothed it out and um,
and it all worked.
Thank fucking Christ.
The only way to make fun of David Ortiz was to just to make fun of how he looked
in the fact that he was a DH.
That's all I had.
And I made fun of the Dominican Republic a little bit.
Um,
and that was it.
That was it.
So I don't know if this video,
I know Gronk fucking killed per joy.
You're killed.
He told this fucking hilarious story about poppy not knowing his first name was
Dustin.
Somebody said to him like,
poppy was in the batter's box,
not the batter's box.
He was on like the on deck circle and pudge.
Roya was stepped out of the batter's box.
The umpire called time out of something,
and the catcher just said hello to Dee,
said,
hey,
what's up?
And when Dustin walked over to poppy to talk to him,
poppy said,
he goes,
what the fuck did that guy just say to you to fuck did that guy just call you?
He's,
he said,
what's up Dustin?
Hey,
Papi was like,
what the fuck does that mean?
He goes,
ah,
that's my first.
It's my first name Bob.
He was like,
Oh yeah,
like he didn't even know
his name was peewee.
So joy is like,
dude,
it's my first name.
They introduced me every time I go up to bat,
I've been going up to bat like 10,000 times.
I bad in front of you.
Every time I come to the plate they say,
now batting number 15 Dustin Pedroia.
And it just,
it never clicked with them.
There's another guy I would have gone to summer school with Petrolia guidance.
Like I think podria got it the worst.
He was hilarious.
He just kept sitting there like,
dude,
what the fuck ever.
You know,
it was just,
I think he got,
you know,
speaking of 11,000 it was like 11,000 short jokes for him.
So there,
there is clips of it up on the Internet.
It wasn't the greatest organized thing was the first time they did it and they
didn't know how to do a roast.
And you can't have people filming at it because Oh,
roast is so over the top.
And that's how people get in trouble and they,
you know,
they take shit out of context and blah,
blah,
blah.
It's completely fucking over the top.
So,
uh,
you know,
I don't know why,
I don't know why they let they let people film.
I don't know why things happened.
Why did things happen like that?
But anyways,
I had to go on dead last in everybody fucking killed.
Lenny went up first killed Adam Ray went up dressed as a Yankee fan named Tony,
and he just told everybody in the crowd to suck his dick and kept trashing.
Yeah.
Okay.
Big Papi and then bragging about the Yankees 27 championships.
And the crowd loved it while they were born and they also so loving it.
He was fucking hilarious.
Um,
Anthony Mackie killed Sarah Tiana fucking destroyed probably at my favorite joke
in the night.
And then,
uh,
fuck,
eh Gronk went up,
killed then [inaudible] and then I had to go up last.
And,
uh,
it's one of those things as you sit there,
you know,
you're kind of losing angles as you go.
So I tried to do,
I tried to just go like a unique way.
So with Gronk I knew everybody was going to say he was stupid.
So I was like,
all right,
I'm going to say smart,
I'm going to go that way with it.
By the way,
by the way.
Um,
he actually was commenting on how he hates going to concerts and everybody sits
there fucking looking at the concept to their phone,
you know what I mean?
How's fucking stupid?
That is,
I love everybody thinks that that guy's dumb.
You know,
like you can make it to the NFL,
memorize the playbook and all of that,
all that fucking shit.
You got to learn and then go out on the field against the top athletes on the
planet and make split second decisions and reactions to how they're reacting to
you and people feel that you can actually get there and just be this big dumb
guy.
I knew he wasn't going to be done when I met him and he wasn't.
So that was a,
uh,
that made the shit that I was going to say about him even better.
I mean,
I did one dumb joke about him being dumb,
but I had to get through it.
I had to do like fucking 10,
12 minutes.
So anyways,
it uh,
it went great.
And my favorite part about it was a,
okay
poppy yelled,
fuck you with me.
I've at least three or four times
and I just kept going,
fuck you too man.
It's a roast.
Do you want it to get roasted?
Here we go.
And uh,
he was such a fucking great guy.
The Guy Really is a rock star man.
His whole vibe is a fucking rock stuff.
So when I finished,
he got up off the chair and came over and gave me a big fucking hug and uh,
and thanked me for doing it.
Just,
it just really like one of the great fucking people I've ever gotten to do
something like that for.
So,
uh,
what was funny is I had,
I had just as much,
I think I had more jokes about Lenny Clark than I did about poppy just cause I
knew him,
which is why I always feel like if you're going to do a roast,
you should know the person.
And,
um,
okay.
What's hilarious is,
uh,
Lenny has been clean and sober for like a quarter of a century and a,
all of my jokes were about him just being a fucking,
you know,
complete mania.
I talked to him basically like he wasn't sober like he had been sober for,
and he was,
you know,
the best guy about a great sport about itself.
Anyways,
long story short,
um,
I got through it and I told you once I got through that Gig,
my,
the whole rest of my year fucking nothing
easy,
easy peasy.
Everything's in my wheelhouse.
It's the weirdest fucking year from me.
I,
all the crazy shit I had to do this month.
MMM.
Oh,
this year was all in this month.
All of this stuff of just,
um,
I haven't thought,
okay,
I haven't sat worried thinking,
how the fuck is this going to go this many times in one month since back when I
first started out doing standup,
which basically every show I was going up thinking like,
ah,
fuck,
commit to your shit.
Get that first laugh,
ride the wave,
don't go over,
say good night.
Get the fuck out of there,
you know,
so,
um,
that's it.
And I'm ready to go to the summer.
The next night we all went to the game,
got to see the retirement ceremony and uh,
it was great.
Man.
Jim Rice was there,
Carl Yastrzemski,
uh,
Veritech,
Pedro Martinez,
MMM Pedroia
came out.
And uh,
I got to see the whole thing,
man,
they took the,
you don't want covered it.
Got to see when they were first put 34 up there.
And um,
I got to admit though,
part of it was sad.
It was like,
fuck,
it's over.
It's over.
Now he's part of the history of the Boston red sox.
And,
Uhm,
I dunno
though.
I think you know all those ceremonies,
man.
They was just remind you that you're going to fucking die.
Oh,
now he's too old to play baseball.
He's too old to fucking play.
And I'm like 15 years fucking older than he is a 10 years older than him,
you know.
See and call you a strip ski coming out with all white hair.
Yeah,
I should have known that was coming.
That guy played until he was like fucking 40.
Okay.
Oh my God,
I'm on nine years older than when that guy retired.
Maybe you played like to like 43.
I don't fucking know.
This is getting depressing.
How do I get out of this?
How the fuck do I get out of this?
Oh,
I know.
Let's talk F1 and fucking Moto GP.
Pete,
Pete.
Um,
okay.
All right,
so race number,
fucking eight or nine of the f one a season in Azerbaijan is that he said
Azerbaijan by Jan,
whatever.
Just east of Georgia and I don't mean fucking Georgia United States,
the country,
Georgia and I guess it's in Asia,
eastern Europe.
I was getting,
it's always weird,
Georgia and all the way over there.
You don't know where the fuck they're at.
One of the coolest cities.
MMM.
On the f one circuit using that word circuit.
Uh,
just a beautiful city.
I would love to go there,
but I definitely looked up like,
is that like a one of those places I shouldn't go?
Should I have like a Canadian,
a fucking flag on my backpack?
Should I speak in an Irish brogue helped when I go there?
Um,
seem like it was pretty safe.
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
I had a great time.
What?
Crazy God damn fucking race.
Congratulations to Daniel Ricardo,
who I think might be the best driver in f one considering he doesn't have the
best engine and he's always on the fucking podium.
Any drink champagne out of his fucking shoot.
So,
you know,
God bless you.
And I don't know about this Lewis Hamilton guy.
I was a fan.
I think he's a fucking great driver,
but I dunno.
Okay.
They said he didn't hit the brakes.
Phil,
you guys don't watch too.
They were under caution and the fucking safety car was out there.
You know,
guys always complain that the safety car drives too fucking slow,
you know,
which cools off their tires.
Then they don't have any grip and then they slam into the fucking wall are into
each other.
Right.
So anyways,
Hamilton was complaining that the fucking guy was driving too slow and then for
whatever reason he hits the brakes really hard and Sebastian Vettel rear ended
him and he was like,
what the fuck?
And then he federal pulls up alongside of them,
slammed his cars and like,
you know,
tire to tire and a,
he got a ten second penalty for that.
And UHM,
I dunno,
I of view it it
and they said to Hamilton,
didn't slam on the brakes,
but I kind of viewed this as one of the,
the ball don't lie.
You know,
they say that basketball when there's some piece of shit file bullshit,
file guide flops,
you go up there and you miss the foul shots.
They,
we see the ball.
Don't lie.
Well only a after that thing they said Hamilton and slam on the brakes.
Hamilton and slam on the brakes and Vettel was guilty of slamming into them and
they only gave him a ten second penalty,
I guess they said they should have been more,
uh,
so be basically,
he has to drive into the fucking pits and sit there for 10 seconds as everybody
keeps going and then drives back out again.
But Hamilton after that,
uh,
that fucking thing that goes around his neck or whatever outside the car,
that thing came loose.
So he had the fucking Poland anyways,
which fucked him over and Vettel still beat him.
So I looked at that like the ball don't lie and Hamilton,
fuck,
I didn't like how he fucking said Deeks says to his team,
say,
bolters said slow down.
He should slow down to help me path federal go fuck yourself.
What about last year when the team called you up to slow down for fucking a Nico
Rosberg and you're like,
Nah,
I'm good.
You were out there driving for yourself.
You know what that guy reminds me of?
He reminds me of a couple of comedians.
I'm not going to fucking mentioned their names when I was on there.
One my way up with them and they were these fucking people.
They were happy if you got something as long as they had more and they would
literally stab your mother in the eye if they could get an inch forward.
That's what I got out of that fucking shit.
Okay.
He should slow down.
Go fuck you got a fucking Mercedes Benz engine that isn't enough for you.
I still like Lewis Hamilton,
but that was kind of girly.
That was kind of girly.
I thought,
you know what I made,
I might be out of my fucking mind.
Yeah.
I don't like that shit.
This is why I don't like about f one is basically the fucking Mercedes and,
and the Ferrari's.
Okay.
If you don't root for either one of those other teams,
every other team,
it's like they're out there driving around in a [inaudible] z 28.
Okay.
And Ferrari and Mercedes,
they're driving around in a corvette,
c o six.
Seeing that lance stroll,
he was like 10 seconds ahead of,
uh,
a boat us.
What happened to him at the early part of the race?
Well,
there were times when the race,
everybody fucking hate each other in the beginning.
So he had to go and he was immediately a lap down.
He's a lab down.
He does his stroke arrays.
Shit like a fucking movie.
Just flies through the entire fucking field.
Okay.
I mean Daniel Ricardo did the same thing,
but he sees in the red bull thing,
they got like an inferior engine.
Like they won't give him one of those Mercedes,
they won't sell a guy a Mercedes or a Ferrari engine cause he knows he,
he'd be too much of a problem.
That's why I think he's the best driver out there cause he's driving around a,
basically a fucking c 28 and he's always up on the podium.
So anyways.
MMM.
For Cindy and my fucking team there,
I don't know what's going on with them.
They got this whole Ricky,
Bobby,
Ricky,
Bobby shit going on,
slamming into each other.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
Okay.
Esteban.
Oh Khan in Sergio Perez.
They basically took each other out of the race.
They would have been on the podium.
One,
possibly two cars and for half a fucking second.
What is it t have the Haas team?
The fucking American team.
Magnuson was like in third place.
All right.
Two of the Williams.
It was the craziest fucking race.
Like the front of the race was Daniel Ricardo like both Williams,
Martini,
Martini racing,
whatever the fuck you say it.
And uh,
Magnuson.
Then of course they all just get run down.
They all get fucking run down.
Both tests was like 10 seconds behind stroll with like 10 laps to go and he
fucking caught him right at the finish line to get second place.
Um,
so that's it.
I can no longer route for fucking Ferrari and I can't root for a Mercedes
because I feel like I'm rooting for the Yankees or the red sox.
Same reason why I root for the red sox.
It's cause I'm from Boston.
What am I supposed to do?
But like,
you know,
they both blow to what?
$1 million,
but not this year.
The Yankees have it.
But I'm just saying generally speaking throughout history,
right.
So I can't,
I can't like pylon
pull a Kevin Durant or Lebron down to Miami or the big three in Boston,
two out of three anyways.
Um,
I can't fucking do that.
So my team,
my teams,
I like,
I like the force Cindy India team and I liked the uh,
the Williams racing team.
That's the coolest looking car,
I think.
I liked that college,
you know,
red,
white and blue.
I guess they used to dominate though.
I got to read up more on the sport.
I don't get how you used to fucking dominate.
Then every bend you just suck.
You know?
I don't get it.
It's not like other sports where you got athletes getting old and dying,
not dying,
retiring,
I should say.
I mean,
if you know how to make a fucking engine work at that level,
shouldn't you just know how to do it?
Yeah,
I know.
I know the driver does count for something,
but gee,
I don't fucking know what I'm saying.
I don't know shit about this stuff.
I just know it's fun to watch.
I guess red bull won like three in a row.
Like,
I don't five,
six years ago,
and then all of a sudden,
what engine where they using then bold,
look it up,
Bill.
I'm afraid to,
I'm afraid to look it up and I'll be like fucking p's and q's and no one will
have an answer.
So I watched that today.
And then I also watched the,
uh,
the Moto GP race,
which was fucking insane.
Both races were great.
The Moto GP race was even fucking better.
Like,
is crazy is that race was sit,
they have a problem with that,
uh,
as or by Jan race where,
because it goes through a city that you don't have those cranes to lift the cars
out of the way in this fucking debris all over the track.
Um,
they actually had a red flag and everybody just pulled in and just stopped.
There's all these guys were running around the track picking up shit from other
cars that is smashed into each other.
As crazy as that race was,
the Moto GP race was,
was the shit.
Valentino Rossi,
he's like 38 fucking years old.
He ended up winning the thing.
Um,
just imagine all the bullshit that was happened.
F One with them bumping into each other.
They're doing it on motorcycles,
going like 150,
200 fucking miles an hour.
Um,
you know,
the,
the guy I liked the best on the,
I mean I always root for Valentino Rossi just cause he's old and I relate and I
want them to keep winning.
So it doesn't make me feel like,
you know,
when he retires.
But God,
there's another guy.
Um,
I liked that.
Johann Johann Zarko,
that guy's a fucking lunatic.
And I also liked the color,
the bike,
the black and the yellow,
whatever they got.
Um,
I liked him,
I liked,
and then I also like,
uh,
the Ducati team,
I liked that.
I say his last name Dove,
the dove is coc z CEO.
So I can't say it,
I can't say someone's got to say,
I've got to watch another 15 races to be able to pronounce that.
D.
O v I.
Z.
I o.
So
xeo.
So Doe Dovi Dovizioso Dovizioso Sad.
I said
German,
Irish,
like we usually have two syllables,
one syllable fucking last name.
I can't,
that's,
that's too many fucking hills.
Dovizioso Andrea Dovizioso Gratzi prego.
Uh,
just an incredible fucking race.
Mac Mac has was in there too.
Um,
and then that fucking lunatic,
the,
the British guy,
cal crutch low.
I don't know where the fuck he came from.
That guy rides like Aluna the way he wrote Yo Zarko I like them.
They're out of their fucking mind.
Um,
so I'm uh,
I'm,
I'm all in on both of those races.
They're so fucking easy to watch.
20 something lapse.
And then the,
uh,
the one today with the cars was like watch like 50 fucking lapse 51.
It's a good God damn time.
And then after that I take my daughter out.
You know,
lot of people when they want to get their babies to fall asleep,
a lot of dads,
what they do is they put them in the car and they drive around and it's
hilarious because the movement makes them go to sleep,
but then you get to a red light and they wake up and they start crying again.
That's why I am a big proponent of the stroller.
All right.
Cause you can keep that fucking thing.
If he has a red light,
you can keep it,
you know,
if you walk in.
And also it's a great way to prevent the dreaded dad bod.
Okay.
All you fucking guys out there,
you throw him in the car and then you drive around,
you know,
then they fall asleep.
And then what do you do?
You hit the drive through because you're tired.
You know,
Arby's,
we have the meats and then you get that fucking sandwich that Osa has a pig on
it.
The pork,
the spare ribs or whatever the fuck they put on there.
The ribs,
the Hoff,
the Hoff.
Um,
yeah,
I've been just walking around my neighborhood and she falls asleep.
And then,
uh,
I just keep walking throughout her whole nap and went through the fucking
poacher,
went to the supermarket,
knock out some errands and she's asleep.
He just keep it fucking moving the whole time.
You throw the groceries on the bottom of the
stroller and that's it.
There's a little dad tip for you.
If you got it,
you got a better one.
I don't know what to tell you.
I do the elliptical while she's still sleeping in the morning.
And then I take a for a trip around the neighborhood.
You got to do it.
He can't,
you can't do the car thing.
Then he got to go out and walk.
Put on your track suits,
right.
Track shoes,
your dad's socks,
you fucking Jean shorts.
Whatever the fuck you got going on.
You're a true religion.
Jeans.
I love that.
I never gave into that fed.
Those were the z Cavariccis a fucking last decade.
Giant stitching with the fucking,
you want to get lucky boy fucking or shoe on the back.
Uh,
there was always something funny about a horse shoe on the ass pockets that
always to me was more gay pride parade than a fucking alien fogging chicks over
there.
But they fuck,
they loved them.
They loved them and speak in a fucking the gay pride parade.
He know it's slowly making a comeback.
And I love it cause I never had a problem with it is rollerblading.
Rollerblading is slowly making a comeback.
I loved it.
And I used to go down the beach with my short shorts on.
Skating backwards.
Kidding?
Little boy.
Short true legend boy shorts.
I did it.
We share.
We all did.
Ah,
there's the Photoshop for the week,
but you know what?
There is no fucking true religion boy shorts that good luck with you on that
one.
Fuck.
Oh mmm no,
I liked it.
I used to play fucking in New York and out in Santa Monica down in Venice beach.
I used to play roller hockey,
hockey and uh,
Jesus Christ catching an edge never hurt more than when you were on in a fucking
parking lot.
You had to go elbow pads,
you had to do it elbow and knee pads.
You just had to fucking do it.
You know,
out there address like robocop because when you went down,
you work,
you were fucked.
I'm,
the only thing that sucked is the hockey gloves.
He didn't have that thing and I actually broke my wrist or broke a bone in my
wrist.
I used to his eye his,
oh my God.
Way Back.
Way,
way,
way back.
Way Back in the fucking day.
I used to play two one to rollerblade hockey at the,
on the top of parking garages in West Hollywood.
Um,
I used to play in with three other comics.
It was me and Dane Cook and it was versus the we all Boston comics versus
[inaudible] and rest his soul.
Uh,
Pete coming.
And,
uh,
I remember we used to,
I remember playing the day of the Superbowl just laughing at how insane the
fucking weather was that it was 80 degrees out.
We went out there,
had a great fucking game,
super,
super highly competitive fucking game.
And we used to play at the top of the parking garage because for whatever reason
on like the Sundays or whatever,
they would just never,
there wouldn't be enough people,
no one at a park on the roof because the car would get all fucking hot on the
inside.
And we would play up there and sometimes someone will park up there,
but no one would ever rat us out in only a couple of times.
Did the ball ever go over the edge?
That I remember,
but we always had like an extra one.
But,
uh,
we do that all the time and it was a great time and,
I never understood why the whole fucking fad went away.
There was one homophobic joke,
one homophobic joke killed the,
and what's the hardest thing about rollerblading?
Telling your parents,
telling,
telling your parents that you're gay.
That one little joke,
the whole fucking thing.
The whole thing went away.
I never understood it.
I got to the point,
I was the one that the guy who took his break off,
that was like a big thing.
When you lived in New York,
you had to be cool yet to take your break off and learn how to stop the other
way.
Like,
yeah,
why would I want to be able to stop quick when I'm skating out in traffic with
cabs and shit?
I can't believe I never died.
Um,
I had a couple of really close calls,
so fucking stupid.
I would never do that again.
I just chalked that up to uh,
being young.
Like I still lived in New York and I was close to Central Park Park Park Park,
and I was going to go roller blading.
I would,
I would at this my age,
I would walk to the park carrying my fucking roller blades.
I have no shame about it.
I know a lot of people are embarrassed that they rollerbladed.
I have no fucking shame.
No shame.
If I lived closer to a boardwalk,
I would own a pair and I would go out there.
It's so much more fun than doing the fucking elliptical.
It's better exercise.
You know,
you put on your wireless headphones,
right?
You tie is tee tee shirt off at the waist and you know,
you go out there and you,
you have a good time.
Maybe you have some tassels on.
I don't know why I am.
I think it's hilarious that everybody got all fucking weird about it.
Um,
as you could tell,
I haven't read any advertising and I haven't done any fucking questions because
a,
I'm recording it early and I still haven't gotten my materials for the week.
Let's hit refresh.
See if they came in.
Let's see.
Nothing,
nothing,
nothing.
No advertising,
no nothing.
All right,
I'll keep talking here.
I'll keep talking.
I'll read the ads and then I'll do the fucking,
I'll do the fucking,
uh,
what do you call it?
Uh,
do the questions.
All right.
Um,
all right.
No Dad Bod,
Ernie talked about that.
Oh,
Billy.
No Fun.
Didn't drink until Friday night.
Um,
took my nephew to the game and after I dropped him off,
I went back into the city and I had a two home pores and a fucking,
uh,
an s in a cigar,
but then I didn't drink last night.
And today I had one course late just because they made the old stubby bottles
again and I just had to add one and it was fucking delicious.
But I don't count that.
I just had one.
I didn't get fucked up.
Um,
anyways,
so I've been doing that shit.
Got To drinking back under control.
And um,
I'm going to find out this week,
by the way,
if there's going to be a season,
three of f is for family,
so I'm a little nervous,
um,
to find out.
So,
uh,
if you haven't watched it yet,
it would really help us if you guys would watch this week to give a nice little
boost.
You know,
I know there's a ton of good shit out there.
Ain't no blood line.
Came back and it was something you guys are working your way through Fargo or
better call Saul.
But uh,
if he could just give us just,
you know,
watch one episode,
something,
anything will help.
Um,
cause we're going to find out this week.
And um,
so anyways,
I went to the red sox Friday night.
Saturday I came home and the angel's game was on against the red sox cause you
know,
I get the angels feed out here and now back into watching baseball.
I'm watching racing and I actually watched the end of the BCA eagles versus the
Edmonton Eskimos.
I watched a CFL game,
I gotta tell you it was highly entertaining because the BC eagles fucking
defense sucks.
MMM.
One of those high scoring games or whatever.
They tied it up and then you know what?
Like tighten it up.
It's like no time left.
The Edmonton Eskimos go out in the first fucking play.
They gave up,
I don't know,
a nice 80 yard meter,
whatever the fuck they call it,
a kilometer of whatever they call it up there a pass.
And then they lost the game,
kicked a field goal and it was over.
And I know a lot of people,
shit on the CFL.
It's on Tsn.
It's good shit.
You know,
I look at it this way,
this is college players that weren't good enough to make it,
you know,
into the end,
into the NFL.
But any,
any one of those CFL teams could beat the best fucking college team out there
cause it's made of college.
All stars like the NFL,
it's college,
all stars.
The NFL is just the best of the best college.
All stars.
The CFL is all the call jol stars that could not make it to the NFL.
So it's still competitive football.
They got that giant field.
I actually enjoyed it.
Um,
I dunno,
I always watched like the Edmonton Eskimos just because like way back in the day
though,
we seem like Doug Flutie and Warren Moon or some shit.
We're always on those teams,
but you know,
I dunno,
BC Eagles came back,
so I was like,
I gotta I gotta Watch these,
I'm going to root for these guys and they fuck the game up.
Um,
all right.
I don't know what else to talk about.
I'm running out of shit.
A congratulations to the lady and in Australia who breastfed in Durham,
in parliament.
I don't know why that was a big deal,
but evidently it's a deal.
I don't know.
I have to be honest with you.
My whole fucking life,
I've never heard one guy ever say that he had an issue with breastfeeding in
public.
I don't know what the fucking problem is.
MMM.
I think it's more for like guys that don't have kids yet and it like grosses him
out cause they're like,
I want to be sticking my face in there and now there's a baby there and that
weirds me out and it makes my chubby go away.
I don't know what the deal is.
I also don't think I,
but I'd be honest with you,
I don't think you should be breastfeeding while you're fucking,
you know,
working for your district,
can,
can we have your 100% focus here?
Okay.
You know,
I dunno,
I,
but I guess guys could go up there and adjust their balls and said,
talking about laws.
I Dunno.
I Dunno why.
I don't know what the big deal is about it.
Uh,
I've seen it my whole fucking life,
but I also don't know why it's treated like somebody just landed on Mars and
came back.
You know,
anything women do is now,
it's just like,
it was so afraid.
It was so groundbreaking,
you know,
they try to act like,
they were,
they weren't brave heart.
So like you fed a baby cause it was hungry.
Um,
ah,
Brian and I just shift to talk about royal blood has a new album out.
Everybody.
No,
I didn't download their first one.
I just downloaded that hit and I played my drums to it a thousand times and I
still suck at it,
you know,
then something,
something to do.
But,
but blue gotta fucking work it out.
Wham,
Bam,
Bam.
Blow blow,
blow,
blow payment.
70.
[inaudible] he did the cabbage do the blue.
However the fucking song goes.
I don't even know the words.
Um,
Wale.
Why did it,
why did a ball,
uh,
royal blood has a new album out and it got good reviews.
So I'm going to download that shit cause I have a fucking,
I got a little rehearsal space.
I was over there today,
was over there today.
I got my fucking life down.
It's perfect.
Wake up in the morning.
I work out.
Right.
Why the kids sleeping?
My wife's sleeping.
Then I run over.
I played drums for a fucking hour.
I come back like a champ and make everybody breakfast.
You know,
I get my bull shit done and then in the afternoon I,
uh,
take my fucking precious little baby girl for a walk.
That's it.
But you know what?
My wife will still find something to complain to me about something.
I'll ask something,
there'll be something I'm doing wrong.
I just feel like I would like it better.
If you,
I feel like for me.
Uh,
all right.
This is the last thing that I've got to hit pause until this fucking shit comes
in.
Uh,
the questions here,
come on man.
Send the fuck questions.
Refresh button.
Hit the refresh button.
Bill,
hit the refresh button.
Nothing.
Wait a minute.
I'm an asshole.
Oh,
it was in the wrong account.
What an asshole.
What an that this the kind of guy doesn't know the difference between
photosynthesis and pollination
fighting under the blue corner.
Here we go.
Ah,
well Lo and behold,
there it is and we go out.
It's time for some advertising.
I was just going to give you guys a fun bit.
Baseball fact.
Remind me when I come back,
he can't,
but I'll,
you know.
All right.
Oh
Dotomi Andy's me undies.
They used to be two all star games due to to to days [inaudible] between 1959 in
and everybody went up to play their balls hurt.
They didn't know what to do cause it's so tomato wall data and have far,
that one sucked.
I got to take two on that one.
I tried to give you the all state,
there was two all star games in 1959 60,
61 and I believe 62,
um,
I might as well give it to you now,
right?
Might as well tell it to you.
Why not?
You know,
why it is,
do you know why they had to all star games now?
Because you know,
people couldn't afford to travel.
So they had one on the east coast,
one on the west coast.
It wasn't that,
it wasn't heavy.
Okay.
It turns out that uh,
playing of the second game was intended to increase the amount of money going to
the players pension fund.
Uh,
as a person says,
I wish there was a need or reason than that,
like gambling demands or trial formation of an allstar league,
which would be made up of two teams of all stars.
They played each other a hundred times a season,
but nope.
Pension Fund.
That's it.
And everybody realized by 1962 or so that the arrangement was dumb.
Uh,
the public at large is finding a second all star game,
something of an anticlimax like playing a second world series in Brazil.
So 1951,
1960,
61,
1959,
sorry,
60,
61.
They played to all star Games.
There you go.
And I learned that this weekend when I saw a pennant from Fenway about the 1961,
all star games and they called the Cincinnati reds by the way,
the red legs,
which I had never heard of either.
Hey Bill,
why don't you get to the advertising?
Because that was some of the most boring shit I've ever listened to in my life.
Hey,
hey,
hey.
Fair enough.
Ah.
Doto me,
Andy's me undies.
Mind your fucking cues and ps to do to to me undies.
Me undies.
I can't fucking sing it this week I got nothing this week my brain is fried for
rhinos.
Roast for y'all because I thought if I was ended with peas and gave me some
around me,
undies mean Andy's mine.
Your fucking p's and q's to do to me undies.
Mandy's.
Don't pee pee or do the Doodoo and you're fucking bell did fucking underwear.
If you shed,
no one will care because it will be soft and cradle the air in the terrain of
your fucking ass groves.
All right,
me and he's everybody talk about why you think it's important to have great
underwear.
Well cause it doesn't ride up on your balls in air.
You perfected your wardrobe.
But what about the stuff?
Everybody every not gets to cs c sorry if you've been settling for store,
bought underwear,
five packs.
I have something that will change your life for the better.
It's me undies.
Everyone.
What's the first thing you put on the last thing you take off?
It's your underwear.
Athleisure.
Matthew mcconaughey.
Make your most important piece of clothing the best it can be with me undies.
What is me undies?
Seriously soft.
Feel good undies delivered right to your front.
Deal with me.
UNDIES are designed in La and made from sustainably sourced that micro modal
modal of fabric.
Three times softer than cotton.
Why don't we clean out our ears with it then me or wipe our ass with it.
I mean if you just telling me that this shit is better than cotton ball,
kiss cotton is natural me undies softer than soft luxury undies come in and ever
changing selection of classic colors,
bold shades and adventurous patterns.
So you can tailor your undies to your own personal style.
And guess what?
You can save time and money each month with a monthly subscription.
And if you're not ready for a scription heads,
okay man,
you can still save.
That's because me is offering 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL me undies.com/burn and get 20% off your first pair.
Once again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr ha me undies.com/burr oh I love it.
There's only three or four reads this week.
All right.
Hallux Helix.
Your unique.
You're a special little fucking snowflake.
You know,
walk like everyone else.
Talk like everyone else showed,
Shat uh,
sleep life for everyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
Because a truly customized mattress will cost you five to $10,000 until now.
Go to hell and sleep.com he leaks,
answer a few simple questions and they'll run a three d biomechanical model of
your body through their proprietary algorithms they've developed with the help
of the world's leading irrigant comics and biomechanics experts.
The result,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on,
he looks Hellickson.
Customers report at 30% improvement in overall sleep quality and for couples for
fucking,
they customize each side of the mattress.
You could fuck your,
uh,
you can fuck somebody else and while your partner's still sleeping,
your mattress arrives at your door and about a week and the shipping is 100%
free.
That's why every morning from Gq magazine to Forbes are all talking about,
he likes sleep.com.
You'll let you have 100 nights to try it out.
And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free groves and give you 100% refund.
No questions.
Jacks ass,
go to hell.
It's sleep.com/burr and get $50 off your order.
That's helix sleep.com/burr ha ha.
I like sleep.com/burst spelled h e l I x dollar Shave Club,
dude.
Dollar Shave Club is the smarter choice.
I talked to this guy this weekend,
the,
he had like one of those Boston accents that it sounds like he's slurring.
I'll try to recreate it.
You'll get a gray shave and a great price conveniently delivered right to your
door.
I know you no longer have to Schlep to the store to buy a cheap disposable
razor.
They gives you a cheap shave.
Dude.
I spent a fortune on razors with gimmicky shit.
I can't even do it.
Gimmicky shaving tech technology you don't even need,
and when you use a uh,
dollar shave club's executive razors with their Dr. Carver,
okay.
The blade just gently glides,
giving you a smooth shave.
Dr Carver's shave butter is transparent for a more precise shave,
helps prevent ingrown hairs and feels great on your balls.
Make the smarter choice by joining Dollar Shave Club for a limited time.
New members can get their first month of the executive razor with a tube of
Garvey's.
She's each shape for only $5 off for only $5 with free shipping.
After that,
razors are just a few dollars a month.
That's a $15 value for only five bucks.
There are no hidden fees,
no commitments cancel anytime you like.
You can only get this offer exclusively@dollarshaveclub.com that's dollar shave
club.com one more for God's sakes,
are old friends.
Shoot old acquaintance be forgot and their copy not be red stamps.com stamps
save you time and money,
but you can use to grow your business.
You can mail any letter,
any package using just your computer or Predator and the mailman comes and picks
it up.
That's right,
the mail man.
He's not breastfeeding while he walks to the God damn mailbox and he's grabbing
his balls,
walking right up to walk.
Avoid the hassle man of the post office and mail everything from postcards to
envelopes to packages,
domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and no
long term commitments.
Unlike the post office stamps.com never closes.
Print,
postage or letters or package for what?
Print postage for letters or packages at your,
at your convenience.
24,
seven keywords descriptions,
convenient,
easy,
reliable,
flexible.
A stamps.com brings all the service of the US post office right to your
fingertips.
Buy and print official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer and printer.
Uh,
no need to lease an expensive postage meter.
I use stamps.com anytime I'm selling posters afterwards.
My after my show is if I want a whore myself out,
if I can figure it out,
God damn it.
You can't too.
And right now you too can enjoy stamps.com service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm
commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter.
Thanks frigging God,
I'm done with that shit.
I hate doing a lot of reads to him in the summer.
All right,
here we go.
Let's read some of the content,
some of the content.
Oh,
hey,
I got it.
I got to promote a Paul Versey show.
Paul Versey with the hilarious Mike Favor.
Mint our co headlining a comedy show to help raise awareness to fight.
That's film intervening,
getting high team.
Okay.
[inaudible] Christ has a fucking mouthful at a nonprofit that helps young
adolescents tell inspiring stories through film and video creations that help
curb the opiate epidemic.
Uh,
founded by oxymoron writers.
Oxymorons writer slash.
Director Johnny Hickey.
You ever see that movie?
That's a good one.
Checked that one out there.
Doing the show at the cow loon on route one in Saugus this Thursday,
July 29th,
seven to 10:00 PM free buffet with ticket purchase a of $40.
All right,
go to the [inaudible] route one saga.
Some of the best fucking Chinese food you ever going to have.
Paul Versey.
Mike favor men are going to fucking kill it.
Seven and 10:00 PM but seven seven dash 10:00 PM and there's two shows.
One show seven to 10.
I don't know what it is.
Look it up.
Alright,
Kyle alluded.
Route one Saugus.
All right,
three drink rule.
Hey,
Bilbo bag,
tits.
I have three drinks tonight and went home.
I feel great about myself from a fellow adult.
Ooh,
little shade there in the end.
I Dunno.
Do three drinks.
She'll become a bloated fat.
Fuck
yeah,
he had three drinks and then you drove home.
What kind of drinks?
Um,
all right,
here's,
here's one for you buddy.
I drank probably over 300 days last year.
I don't feel good about myself.
Um,
and me needing to shut it down in no way should make you feel self conscious
about what you're doing to the point you have to be country to me and say you
feel great about yourself.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
So good for you.
Keep having three drinks tonight and feeling good about yourself when you don't
feel good about yourself.
Shut it down.
You know what I'll do?
I'll
cancer charities,
Sham.
Oh,
here we go.
Here we go.
Here's another one.
In a rare joint action with the attorney or attorneys general for each of the 50
states,
the Federal Trade Commission says for cancer charities run by extended members
of the same family con donors.
Out of a $187 million from 2008 to 2012 and spent almost nothing to help actual
cancer patients and what happens to these people and they're going to go to jail
children's cancer fund.
All right.
Let's see.
In a rare of a vibrate,
each of the charities charge where the subject of extensive reporting by CNN in
2013 I,
cause I remember this story and in each instance none of the four charities
would comment.
We were ordered out of the building at the cancer fund of America in Knoxville,
Tennessee.
Oh,
on the Tennessee voluntary,
uh,
and worthy object of an abyss,
of an obscene gesture by the CEO of the breast cancer society.
Am I,
that's usually,
that's usually a good sign that it's bullshit.
If you're raising money for cancer to help kids stricken with cancer and you're
the CEO and you give the finger of media which is going to help promote,
yeah,
that's probably a good sign.
The Cancer Fund of America is run by James rendered senior,
his son,
James Rental Junior.
This is all alleged,
by the way,
before these scumbags allegedly start to sue me for reading.
This is the CEO of the breast cancer society and other charity.
The child's cancer fund of America is run by Rose Park and the ex wife of the
elder James Reynolds,
he is,
he's also the CEO of the Fourth Charity Cancer Support Support Server Services.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
Well,
if they're doing dirt,
I hope they get caught and they go to fucking jail.
Okay.
Jesus Christ,
man,
that is like some sociopath shit.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
Are you going out buying like a fucking buy yourself a raptor like a fucking,
what could you,
here's something for you.
What could you by yourself
with,
with cancer?
Okay.
Shit that was supposed to go to,
to help kids.
What could you by yourself?
Oh my God.
That at that is that,
I mean that is just,
yeah,
that's just,
that's on another fucking level.
Yeah.
I think even bankers would be like,
really do Jesus Christ.
How about a little fucking little bit of tact?
Something.
Um,
all right.
Transgender habits.
Hey,
Billy muffin top.
Oh,
that's so true.
I listened to Andrea had a few months ago,
maybe even a few years ago.
Oh Jesus.
Sorry.
Losing credibility.
I can't remember.
It was last month or 2010.
I heard his segment.
You might be interested in,
I believe it was this American life,
but they asked a transgendered man.
Uh,
okay.
I don't know what that mean.
A woman becoming a man.
I get it.
I think,
uh,
if there was any interesting changing,
well he talked about after his transition,
he was now more into science,
was way more interested in sex and wasn't able to access his emotions as much
anymore.
Oh.
So those are basically guy things.
Okay.
That's kind of interesting.
I would think way more interested in sex because you're finally a sex.
You want to be
okay.
Science.
That's really interesting and weren't able to access your emotions more.
I Dunno.
I have no idea.
That's,
well,
there you go.
So maybe I wasn't wrong thinking that somebody's habits changed a female
privilege.
Hey Man,
I love your podcast.
Hope your family's doing great.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Wasn't that Nice of you?
My family is doing great.
My daughter is awesome and my wife,
I have a whole new level of love for watching a BMR awe.
Have a read at this article when you get a chance.
Um,
okay.
Female nurse found guilty of dangerous driving,
causing death to be sentenced.
Do I want to read this?
There weren't any kids involved in this.
This,
this con.
We already saw a potential scam.
Okay.
Be Seen or is found guilty of dangerous driving causing death sentence to 90
days in jail.
The families of two young people are angry over a dangerous driving sentence,
giving the woman who killed them,
okay.
The be seniors found guilty of data.
Okay?
Causing death of two people's been sentenced to 90 days in jail
and Alina Hesi Mobic was driving at high speeds through pet pit meadows.
And October,
2010 she ran a red light,
jumped a concrete median and slammed into a car carrying Becky Dyer 19 and
Johnny d all Avera 21 the couple who were on their way home from a concert where
killed instantly along with the 90 day sentence.
Hesi Mobic also received two years provoked probation,
120 hours of community service in three years driving probation.
Okay.
MMM.
She will serve her sentence intermittently between Tuesdays and Thursdays around
her work schedule.
Oh my God.
What a joke.
Diyers.
Mother.
Debbie said,
this sentence is not showing the public that our justice system actually is a
justice system.
It's actually a legal system.
It's not going to deter other drivers from doing the same.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
D all of errors.
Mom,
Audrey echoed the same sentiment.
Six years is a long time.
She's put everybody through and she's only getting a little bit here.
A little bit there.
It's wrong.
Yeah.
That's terrible.
That's fucking terrible.
That's fucking horrible.
Okay.
You know at some point when you're driving that fast,
you do.
I mean,
I think those laws are all going to change.
I know they have with drunk driving.
Yeah.
I think because she wasn't drunk in jails are all filled up,
at least in this country.
Like I don't understand that.
But I mean,
your life should be tremendously effective if you were,
if you were driving that fucking fast and then killed two innocent people.
Okay.
I think the whole,
well,
she's never committed a crime.
She's a nurse.
She's a productive member of society.
I think a lot of that goes out the fucking window.
Well,
she did something tremendously stupid.
And now two people are dead forever.
So at the very least you can do 90 straight days in,
what do you say there and,
and,
yeah,
I guess you'll have to figure out what you're going to fire.
You gonna find another job after that.
What kind of cool job does she have?
I have to be on jail.
I've been in jail on Tuesday and Thursdays because I killed two people on
Tuesday.
I go to jail for the woman I killed on Thursday.
I go to jail for the guy I killed.
So I can,
I work like Monday,
not Wednesdays.
So there'll be like so tired from being jail from one day.
Um,
can I work like Monday,
Friday,
Saturday and a half day Sunday?
Uh,
that's,
yeah.
That's disgusting.
Fucking disgusting.
All right.
My girlfriend is becoming a feminist.
Hey there,
daddy bald,
freckle.
First of all,
English is isn't my mother tongue.
So sorry if I fucked up a bit.
All right.
I was wondering why that
I can just see you googling daddy bold,
freckle and just mashing them.
That's what I would've done.
All right.
And I'm 33 years old and I'm an 80 in an 18 month relationship with a terrific
girl.
After four rather unsuccessful relationship,
I finally had the feeling she could be the one.
Um,
she has her flaws like every person,
but hey,
so do I.
But when it comes down to the important features like honesty,
moral values,
similar lifestyles and interests,
she really is my match.
And to top it all off in bed,
it never gets boring.
Do this is your second language.
This is great.
She's more on the submissive side.
Maybe you just fucking with me.
And he deliberately wrote a bad insult.
Um,
she's more on the [inaudible] side.
If you understand wink in some things,
sometimes get wild,
gross,
gross.
I now have no sympathy for you,
but in a very nice way.
He tries to say after our sexy time session gross,
we lay next to each other.
Comp.
Ah,
completely out of breath,
feeling like nothing can touch his sounds cheesy,
but it's really beautiful.
Why did you go into all that detail?
Oh my God,
that was disgusting.
They would tell you guys how much I can't stand watching people kiss in public
on film Marina.
It's,
it's the grossest fucking thing ever.
Keep your intimacies to yourself.
Uh,
now we have a long distance relationship.
We are far away,
but we still eat.
You see,
still see each other quite often.
Five times per year,
but then usually weeks at a time too.
What the fuck just happened?
What the hell?
What just happened?
Was there a jump in time here?
Was there some time travel going on here?
She lives in Europe and has been hanging out with these feminist activists girls
and she's bringing up the topic of sexism,
et Cetera.
More and more lately now,
I was raised by a proud mother.
Oh Geez.
This is there.
Any other kind,
proud,
strong woman and could not imagine dating a girl that has,
has values of women out of the 1950s I like confident,
proud women.
This is what he always sets himself up to be a good guy that can hold their own.
But even though I am not a chauvinist by any means,
I think the modern feminist movement,
similar to Vegans,
annoying the living,
annoys the living hell out of me.
I get that there is sexism in this world,
but I don't see the huge problem in it,
especially since the western societies have made such progress in this field in
the past decades.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
You keep talking yourself back into the hole there.
Yeah.
Like a total psycho 100% feminist maniac.
You don't want to be around that.
It's literally like being around a conspiracy theorist after awhile as far as,
they're never going to shut the fuck up about that topic and it's gonna drive
you nuts after awhile.
Um,
do you realize that every day 40% of women are going to be throwing stats at
you?
Like someone who plays fantasy football.
Anyway,
he says today,
my girlfriends sent me a link to an article about how pornography objectifies
it's discriminates women.
Then she wrote,
I've been thinking a lot lately and I'll have to change some things in the
future,
especially in our sex life.
Yeah,
dude,
this relationship is over a now.
I tend to agree with now I tend to agree with this auto button.
Nevertheless,
I furiously,
your pied,
Hey,
if you're going to turn it to one of the these nonstop nagging feminist,
please tell me now so I can even move the fuck further away from you and your
victim seeking miserable friends.
Yeah,
dude,
you're kind of an asshole.
You're kind of an asshole.
MMM.
Slash a bit of a control freak,
I think.
I Dunno.
But then you're cool with her moving away.
I don't know.
I can't read you.
He goes,
then things escalated quickly.
Yeah.
You think we got into a big fight and haven't communicated since?
Dude,
it's so rapid.
It was already a rap.
It was already a wrap.
You know,
if you just imagine if you got into something.
Okay.
And then you came home and whatever your new fucking way of thinking was,
you told your wife or girlfriend that she needed to adjust some things in the
bedroom.
I mean,
try that one on for size.
Yeah.
What it is is she's grown in a different direction and she needs to be,
uh,
you know,
I don't know.
She's,
we was with a different type of guy,
not you.
Now Bill,
this is a girl.
This girl is great and smart and TB.
H I don't know what that means.
I am all for women's rights and see sexism on a daily basis and totally
understand some of the way I would stop fucking making yourself out to be the
hero.
I'm not one of these guys,
but I'm not one of these guys.
So leave me the fuck alone with this stuff and if this stuff will interfere with
our sex life and changed the woman that I have learned to love,
I don't know where this will leave us.
What do you think of this?
Am I being too non empathetic here?
It's been,
I don't think you're an empathetic person.
Um,
I would say that,
uh,
yeah,
I,
this is a wrap.
This is not the kind of woman you're looking for.
Um,
and this is a major change in her.
All right.
I mean,
I don't know what goes on between the two of you,
but if she's going to be like,
hey,
watch this and we need to change some stuff in the bedroom,
like the,
the relationship as you know,
it is over and uh,
and it's long distance.
I mean,
yeah,
it's,
it's a fucking rap.
I would walk away.
Um,
all right.
Fucked up at,
at pet shop.
Last one here.
Fucked up at the pet shop.
He's where's dad goes pet shop boys.
That's right.
And I fucked up at pet shop.
How's it going?
Oh,
Billy Bordeaux.
Bullocks.
Um,
love the podcast.
Congrats to the guy.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
All the great work on F is for family bag east.
Haven't laughed at anything so hard and long time old.
Billy.
I fucked up recently,
but no one knows I've done anything wrong.
I work in a pet shop,
we sell rabbits and mice,
things like that.
And my job is to feed them and clean their cages.
I already don't like where this is going.
Not the most exciting thing in the world,
but I love animals and they look so sad a lot of the time,
so I try to make their lives a little better by looking after them the best I
can.
That's what I would do if I worked at a pet store.
Long Story Short,
I'm fairly new,
so the first day I was taught how to tell the male rabbits from the female
rabbits.
Turns out you have to feel for the testicles,
which wasn't that hard as a lot of the rabbits had really big balls like holy
shit and I was pretty confident that I could do it in the future.
God,
these are weird this week.
Fast forward to Monday,
turns out I cannot do it.
We've got a whole load of new Lionhead rabbits in with massive for making it
almost impossible to locate the balls.
We'll just flick them between the legs.
If the rabbit turns around like what the fuck was that for it?
She has a pussy.
You fucking flicking between the legs and the thing collapses,
you know,
and lays there for 30 seconds while his other friends laugh at him.
Uh,
that is a male and the ones laughing.
Well,
women laugh at that shit too.
Anyways,
at that stage it was just me and one of the student,
part time workers who probably had just learned to locate his own balls,
let alone someone else's.
Uh,
why is this a big deal?
Well,
I can tell you,
I,
I think you can figure out,
we can,
why we can't put the males in with the females bill.
I seriously don't know what the fuck happened,
but I went home that evening having no idea if I was going to arrive back into
work with double the number of rabbits.
I know that's not how gestation works,
but fuck it.
Uh,
what would you do if you were in my situation?
I just started working here and I really like it,
but I have no idea how.
Explain how I fucked this up so badly.
Thanks.
Well,
what happened?
We've got a whole new low of new line,
had rabbits in with massive for making it almost impossible.
So what is this,
what is the problem here?
You're worried that you're going to put them in with the wrong ones and a taf
fuck.
Oh my God.
I just dropped my fucking laptop on my foot.
Ah,
Jesus Christ.
Um,
I don't know what the problem is,
sir.
What I would do is I would come clean before you have 7,000 rabbits and they got
to feed them to the snakes.
That's what I would do.
All right.
How hard is it to find fucking balls?
I'd put on a glove and I go,
you're like underneath them.
You know Dennis had done it,
a Buddhist about it up.
I don't know.
I don't know why you're out of my,
I'm out of my element.
I don't know what to tell you.
I don't know how to find rabbit balls.
I would definitely come clean and say that you think you fucking messed up
because a,
the fact that you're running from this problem like that guy in Fargo.
Ah,
gees.
I'm going to get you the numbers like you're doing that right now.
All right?
And I'm afraid you're going to end up blaming the fucking college student.
So I would just come clean.
Say that you fucked up.
I don't think they're going to fire you over it.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
that's what I would do,
and I would learn how to find rabbit balls.
I would get into an Atlanta business.
All right?
Okay,
there you go.
That's the podcast for this week.
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
If you'd like to contribute to this podcast,
just go to a Netflix and watchF is for family this week.
If you don't want to do that,
go to my podcast page.
Click on the go my website,
click on the podcast page,
and if you're going to buy something on Amazon,
just click on the Amazon link.
It takes you there.
I get credit for driving traffic and they kicked me a little Delray meal with a,
okay,
that's it.
Go fuck yourselves and I will talk to you on Thursday.